So last night we tried to argue that saving faith is the awakening, the coming to life of the enjoyment of Jesus.
And if that's true, then since saving faith is a obligation for all human beings, therefore
the enjoyment of Jesus would be an obligation, a duty, a requirement.
A lot of people stumble over that claim that to enjoy Jesus is required of us.
It's an obligation.
So I'm posing the question in this message, is that a biblical way to think?
Should you even think about, okay, when I get up tomorrow morning,
One of the things God requires of me is that I enjoy Him that day.
It is a requirement that feels very strange to a lot of people.
So that's my question this evening.
And I invite you to turn with me to Psalm 1611, a well-known text around here, right at the heart of what we do at Desiring God and Bethlehem College in seminary.
So let me read just this one verse on our way to give six reasons for why it is biblical to make the pursuit of the enjoyment of God, the vocation of your life, the calling and obligation, a very high priority, not something peripheral, but something essential.
You, God, this is verse 11, Psalm 16, you make known to me the path of life.
In your presence, there is fullness of joy, and in your right hand are pleasures forevermore.
So Father, as we look at this verse and then broaden out our sight to the rest of the Bible, would you come and get glory
While we get to joy and I pray that in this room, those who find it foreign or alien to their life, that the enjoyment of Jesus would be paramount, would be saved.
That you would bring saving faith into their lives and thus awaken the enjoyment of Jesus.
I ask for this miracle in Jesus' name.
Amen.
So seven brief observations about this verse.
Number one, there is a path that leads to the presence of God.
You may know to me the path of life.
There's a path of life.
Get on it, right?
Are you on it?
That would be the question that the Holy Spirit would be pressing on you if you were meditating on this verse.
Am I on that path?
Number two, God is the one who makes the path known.
You make known to me the path of life.
So He directs us to it.
He puts us on it.
Number three, that path leads to fullness of joy, not 99% proof joy, but 100% proof joy.
If the world offers me 98% joy and God offers me 100%, I'm not taking the world.
That would be stupid, right?
Most people are stupid.
I mean, it's really insane.
It's suicidal and it's insane.
If God offers you full joy for you to take anything less is self-destructive.
Fourth, this path leads to joy forever.
So not just full, but
forever.
So I'm not interested in the offer of 80 years of joy.
And then hell, I'm not interested in the offer of 80 million years of joy.
No, thank you.
I want joy forever, which is why I love to, I love to commend Christianity.
I love to preach and say, come on, be a Christian.
You cannot improve upon this offer.
There's nothing fuller than full.
There's nothing longer than forever.
Why would you not come?
Number five, this promise to have full and forever joy is in Christ.
Now, that's not in the verse.
However, we're Christians.
What we know is that as the Old Testament,
redemptive history unfolds.
It comes to its fullness in Jesus as he comes into the world and is the Messiah and thus the fulfillment of the Old Testament.
So you read a verse like this.
2 Corinthians 1, 20, all the promises of God find their yes in Jesus.
So this promise, 16, 11, in my presence, God says, is fullness of joy, pleasures forevermore,
Jesus comes and purchases it for sinners.
The only reason anybody could enjoy this in the Old Testament is because Jesus was going to shed his blood for sinners.
So it's not artificial to say this verse was purchased for us by Jesus.
So if you are in Christ tonight, it's yours.
You don't have to say, oh, but that was made as a promise to Israel.
It's not made to Gentiles like me.
Yes, it is because you are in the Messiah.
He is the Jew and now everything promised to Israel is yours in Messiah Jesus.
Number six, the full and lasting joy is in God's presence.
It's nowhere else to be found.
He is not holding this out as one of many options like, oh, you can find full and lasting joy in my presence and you can find full and lasting joy elsewhere.
That's not what the verse means.
The verse means if you're gonna have full joy and forever joy, it will be from God, in God's presence, and therefore, number seven, it's an obligation, as we're going.
It's an obligation.
He's not pointing you to this path to say, you don't have to do this.
And there are other ways to life.
There are other paths to life.
There aren't.
There's one path to life.
One path to joy, one path to God, and Jesus is saying, God is saying, get on it.
Get on it.
It's one of the happiest obligations you will ever have.
I mean, it is the happiest obligation you will ever have.
It's a duty, it's a requirement.
Get on the path that leads to your full and forever joy.
Now,
It might be gratuitous to ask, why have I given the last 55 years of my life to thinking about that reality, that obligation and written book after book about it and grow up a school and a ministry around it?
Why have you given yourself to this?
I mean, couldn't it be that this thing that you call enjoying Jesus or Christian hedonism is
just a warmed-over form of prosperity gospel, kind of prosperity light, that horrible stuff that we have exported around the world by American Christianity.
Maybe it's just that.
Or maybe it's just a disguised form of pop psychology fitting right in with the American meism
And of course, people are going to like to hear this because we're all into ourselves and Piper's going around the country saying, indulge yourself on full and forever joy.
How easy does that fit into sin?
Or maybe it's just true, but it's marginal and Piper treats it as central.
Now, I don't think any of those three is true or I wouldn't be here.
So let me give you four reasons before I even give you my six reasons.
Six reasons for why it's an obligation.
And four reasons why I care.
Like why did we accept this invitation?
We got things to do, right?
I'm old.
I'm trying to finish some projects and I keep interrupting them to do things like this.
Why did I do this?
And I have four reasons and they're a big deal.
You will see that very quickly.
Number one, it has this, enjoying Jesus, this church with that tagline, enjoying Jesus, the pursuit, the obligation of full and forever joy in God's presence has everything to do with suffering.
And every person in this room will suffer.
No exceptions.
I know that not because of life,
enough to teach me, but because of the Bible.
Through many tribulations, we must enter the kingdom of God, Acts 14, 22.
Whoever would live a godly life in Christ Jesus will be persecuted.
2 Timothy 3, 12.
If anyone would come after me, let him deny himself and take up his cross, which is the place to suffer and die.
Matthew 16.
We are fellow heirs with Christ, provided we suffer with Him in order that we may be glorified with Him.
You're going to suffer, Christian.
This issue of enjoying Jesus has everything to do with doing that well.
If you don't get this, you won't suffer well.
That's number one.
I care about your suffering and therefore I care about making plain what enjoyment
of Jesus is and isn't.
Number two, why do I care?
It has everything to do with loving other people.
The Bible says, if you love your neighbor, you have fulfilled the whole law.
That's a big deal, right?
That's huge.
You can fulfill the whole law.
How?
By loving people.
Love your neighbor as yourself has, you have fulfilled the whole law, Romans 13, 10.
How is that?
Well, what's more loving?
I mean, can anything be more loving than to lay down your life in order to bring other people into full and forever joy.
There isn't any greater love than to bring people into full and forever joy at the cost of your life.
You can't give what you don't have.
It's a fake.
You're just a fake.
If you think you're giving what you don't have, and therefore if you are indifferent to enjoying Jesus, you can't love people.
Now I'm coming back to that, so I'll leave it right there.
That's a big deal to me.
I would like this church to love people better.
I would like to love people better.
You can't love people better if you don't enjoy Jesus.
Number three.
It has everything to do with the glory of God.
The glory of God is the greatest reality in the universe.
God is the greatest reality in the universe.
His glory is the outshining of himself and it is impossible that you make God glorious if you desire other things more than God.
You cannot do it.
and therefore the enjoyment of Jesus is essential to glorifying God.
We'll come back to that one as well.
You see how massive this is for me?
Suffering, love, God, glory, it's just huge.
We're not talking about marginal things in this conference.
This church is not about marginal things.
Like let's have a cute little tagline.
What would work in Middle-Othean?
Well, maybe
enjoying Jesus.
That's just a lot of baloney.
This is as deep and as central, as glorious as it gets.
That's why I'm here.
I don't like marginal stuff.
Number four, it has everything to do with your identity as a human being.
Now this has come to the front for me because of artificial intelligence.
If you say five years ago were asked, what's right at the core of being in the image of God?
If you had said, it's the capacity to reason.
Almost everybody was, yeah, that's an important part of it.
The capacity to reason.
God is a rational being.
And he has made us in his image and we are rational beings.
And then you wake up one morning and machines can think better than you and talk better than you.
And they can.
They can.
They can outthink you and out speak you.
Now what becomes of your humanity?
That's not the essence of who you are.
The essence of who you are is the spiritual capacity of your soul to see and savor the glory of Jesus.
No machine will ever see and savor, enjoy, be passionate about Jesus.
It won't ever happen.
It will think, it will not feel.
It will say, I feel,
program it to say anything.
It won't feel.
I mean, this has just been huge for me recently as I've seen how what we've given our lives to for the last 50 years is so pointedly relevant and so essential for the very nature of human being.
Okay, so no, it's not prosperity gospel.
No, it's not a bit of pop psychology.
It's everything.
It's my life.
It's your life.
Okay, now we go to the six reasons.
The six reasons for why your pursuit of the enjoyment of Jesus full and forever is an obligation.
A very, very happy obligation.
Number one, it's commanded.
It's commanded in the Bible.
You heard this if you were in Marshall's seminar today.
Psalm 37, four, delight yourself in the Lord is not a suggestion.
It's a command.
Psalm 32, verse one, be glad in the Lord and rejoice you righteous ones.
Shout for joy, all you are
who are upright in heart, that's a command.
Psalm 67 verse four, let the nations be glad and sing for joy, for you will judge the peoples with uprightness and guide the nations on the earth.
Isn't it wonderful that world missions means going to tell the nations to be happy?
That's just wonderful.
It may cost you your life.
I mean, I do funerals for missionaries.
I know this will cost you your life.
I promise my people there will be martyrs in this church.
Come on, let's do this.
The Great Commission won't be finished without blood.
It says so in Revelation.
The martyrs are up there waiting and Jesus says, the full number of the martyrs isn't in yet.
It can't end history.
It's a serious business.
But what we're doing is saying, let the nations be glad.
We're telling the best news in the world, Psalm 100.
Make a joyful noise to the Lord, all the earth.
Serve the Lord with gladness.
It's a command.
Now, that's argument number one.
And there are two objections, two objections to it.
And these objections are right under my history.
The first objection is, I was on a panel with Elizabeth Elliot.
Elizabeth Elliott was, was, is one of my heroes.
I liked her.
I liked just by everything about her.
She was blunt.
She was straightforward.
She was in your face.
I just thought she was the coolest lady.
And now Johnny Eriksantata has kind of taken her place.
So I get these two women in my life that, besides my wife, that are just awesomely inspiring to me.
Okay, women.
Here's what she said.
Gotta have to correct Elizabeth Elliott.
So I'm on this panel with her.
She's 20 years older than I am.
I checked that out this afternoon, born in 26.
She's in heaven with Jesus.
Got this all straightened out now.
And she said flat out in front of 2,000 people.
John, I don't think you should tell people to pursue joy.
I think you should tell people to pursue obedience.
And I've heard this before, so this is not catching me off guard, right?
And I said, I didn't call, I probably did not call her Elizabeth because I was in my 40s probably and she was in her 60s and I don't call women in their 60s by their first name.
When I'm 40, I do now.
I said, that's like saying don't tell
people to eat apples, tell them to eat fruit.
You get that?
Because obedience means doing what you're told.
And what we're told is to be glad in God.
Right?
It's a command.
You can't play obedience off of an obedient act.
It will work.
I think I won that argument.
I wouldn't change anything about her.
She's going around the country telling people to die for Jesus.
That's the name of her biography of Amy Carmichael, right?
Anybody know the name of her biography?
A chance to die.
I love this.
So I'm not asking her to change her language, but I'm telling her, you can't make me change mine either because it's biblical.
You're just biblical, mine's biblical.
That's objection number one.
It is not fair to say to Piper, you should tell people to obey God instead of enjoy God.
Because enjoying God is obedient to the command to enjoy God.
Objection number two, here I am a sophomore, I'm a junior in college and I took a class on apologetics from Millard Erickson.
He had us read a bad book, and he knew it was a bad book because that's how he did apologetics, named Situation Ethics by Joseph Fletcher.
And in the book, now here's one of the great advantages of growing up in a church and in a home where it's all Bible saturated because you develop a good sniffer, right?
You can't explain what's wrong, but you smell it.
It's wrong.
Something's wrong.
And so I'm reading this book, and here's the argument.
Love for people cannot involve the emotions because it's commanded, and you can't command the emotions.
Some's wrong with that.
I've never heard anybody argue like that, but I said, that doesn't smell right to me.
Now you know why that doesn't smell right to me?
Because emotions are commanded all over the Bible.
Come on Joseph Fletcher read the Bible and you I just want to pause here and say All you people who don't have PhDs in theology You've got noses and if you if you grew up with the aroma of the gospel and the aroma of an inspired Bible You're going to be guided by that good sniffer all through life and all these liberal PhDs are going to try to tell you things like
That doesn't work in the Bible.
That's just wonderful.
So just keep reading your Bibles and you'll be on the path.
So what's the answer to that?
The answer is, desires are commanded.
1 Peter 2, 2, like newborn babes desire the pure spiritual milk.
Contentment is commanded.
Hebrews
13, be content with what you have.
Hope is commanded.
Hope in God.
Psalm 42, fear is commanded.
Fear the one who can throw soul and body into hell.
Luke 12, zeal is commanded.
Well, I got a list of 25 things that are commanded here.
That's enough.
God can command you to do whatever you ought to do, whether you can do it or not.
That's a certain theology.
And it's true.
If you ought to delight in God and you find that you can't, you still ought to, and God has every right to tell you to do what you ought to do.
And you just need to be born again.
You've got to have a new heart.
That's what's scary about Christianity.
We can't control it.
God has to save people.
We can't save people.
Okay, that's argument number one, it's commanded.
Argument number two for why it is biblical to treat the enjoyment of Jesus as an obligation.
It is the meaning of conversion.
Now we saw this last night, so I'll be light on this and take you just one new text.
Here's Matthew 1344.
I love this one verse parable.
The kingdom of heaven is like a treasure.
Matthew 1344.
The kingdom of heaven is like a treasure hidden in a field.
which a man found and covered up.
And then from his joy, he goes and sells everything he has and buys that field.
What is that?
That's the end of the parable, one verse parable.
What's the point of it?
The point of it is that becoming a Christian, coming into the kingdom of God, is the discovery of a treasure.
That's what I meant last night when I said saving faith is the awakening of the enjoyment of Jesus.
So you stub your toe by grace on a chest hidden in a field.
You reach down, you open the chest.
It is full of gold, millions and millions of dollars worth of gold.
The rules in the day are you own the fields, you own the treasure.
I got to buy this field and you sell everything you have.
And the catch phrase is, from joy, he goes and sells everything he has.
And the people at the pawn shop must have thought he was crazy because he's selling his computer and above all things he's selling his books.
He's selling his books and nobody understands why he's so happy to let go of all this world stuff.
And the answer is he's found Jesus, the King.
So what is the enjoyment of Jesus?
It is conversion.
When you're converted, you find a treasure.
When you find a treasure with joy, you sell everything you have, or you're willing to sell everything you have.
You hold loosely everything in Middle-Othean or wherever you live, you hold it loosely.
That's why you're willing to die.
do hard things for Jesus because you have the greatest treasure in the world and it lasts forever, full and forever.
So that's argument number two, it's an obligation because it's what it means to be saved, it's what it means to be converted, the discovery of the treasure of Jesus.
Number three, it's a duty to pursue your enjoyment of Jesus because the teaching of self-denial
is based on it, not contradictory to it.
It's amazing how many people throw up the doctrine of self-denial as a problem for me.
as a problem for Christian hedonism, as a problem for pursuing the enjoyment of Jesus.
How can you go around the country telling people to indulge themselves on God as completely satisfying forever when the Bible says, Jesus says, if you're going to be a disciple, you've got to deny yourself.
How can you do that?
My response is to say, look, nowhere does the Bible command ultimate self-denial?
And if it did, it would be blasphemy.
For example, so here you are at heaven's gate.
End of your life, you've died and you're knocking on the door.
and Jesus comes to open the door.
And there's a big smile on his face because you're a Christian, you trust Jesus.
And a big smile on his face and he says, welcome into my presence where there's fullness of joy and pleasures forevermore.
And you say, no, no, no, no, no.
We've been taught that the essence of Christianity is self-denial and we are not about
to break that rule and start indulging our enjoyments.
That's blasphemy.
That's a slap in his face.
Now, is that biblical what I just said?
I mean, that's clever, but is it biblical?
So here's the key phrase.
Everybody knows where this is coming from.
It's coming from Mark 834.
If anyone would come after me, let him deny himself and take up his cross
It doesn't get any more horrible than that.
The cross was an absolutely horrible, horrible, horrible experience.
It's not a gold thing hanging around your neck.
It is a place of torture and misery drawn out as far as it can.
So take up your cross and deny yourself and follow me.
So there's the
There's just no doubt.
Self-denial is a reality in the Christian life, okay?
It's right there.
We must deny ourselves.
Now the question is, deny ourselves what?
In order to what?
And here's the next verse.
Because, starts with four.
Four means because.
or because whoever would save his life will lose it.
Pause.
If you don't want to lose your life, that's the assumption, right?
If you would try to save your life, you're going to lose your life.
You don't want to lose your life, so be sure to lose your life.
That's the argument.
Next phrase, but whoever loses his life
For my sake and the gospels will save it.
You want to save your life?
That's the argument.
Jesus is assuming the pursuit of joy.
He's assuming it.
He's not contradicting it.
He's building his whole argument on it.
If you want to save your life, lose your life.
If you want to lose your life, spend your whole life trying to save your life.
So you just have to think, no, what in the world does that mean?
What does that mean?
And it means that you have found a treasure in a field and you're willing to sell everything to have it.
That's self-denial.
He sold everything and he left the country and he spent 40 years in India.
That's the pursuit of maximum pleasure by denying himself everything in order to have that.
That's the argument.
Ultimate self-denial is blasphemy.
And ultimate gratification in God is worship.
We always deny ourselves lesser things to have greater things.
I don't know if you know the author of Atlas Shrugged, Ironran, the Russian philosophical atheist who wrote this book that just captures a lot of people.
And Ironran, I wrote her a letter, a long letter while she was still living, to see if I could
do anything because she rejected Christianity outright because she thought that Christianity taught denial of greater things for lesser things.
That's what she said.
I hate altruism, she said.
I hate Christianity.
It teaches altruism, meaning you lay down your best in order to embrace the worst.
And I wrote her along.
arguments that is not what it teaches.
Gave her my best Christian hedonist arguments because she was trying to be a hedonist and she didn't know how.
Because you leave God out of the picture, which he did, you cannot make sense out of the Bible or Christian reality.
Okay, that's argument number three.
The doctrine of self-denial is there, it's real, it's required, it's just not ultimate.
We deny ourselves temporary, inadequate, insufficient pleasures in order to have God and His fullest possible and longest joy.
That's number three, number four.
The reason that the enjoyment of Jesus is essential
and obligatory is because the opposite of it is the definition of evil.
If you reject the pursuit of enjoyment of Jesus as the goal of your life, you will become an evil person.
Here's the key text from which I get that.
This is Jeremiah 2, 12.
Be appalled, O heavens, at this, be shocked, be utterly desolate, because declares the Lord, for my people have committed two evils.
So what is evil in this verse?
Like, that people have committed two evils, Jeremiah 2, 13.
They have forsaken me
the fountain of living water.
Two, they have hewn out, dug out for themselves cisterns, broken cisterns that can hold no water.
So what is evil?
I think this is the essence of all evil.
This is the evil of evil.
The evil of evils is to taste God
sample God and turn away and say, yuck.
Hell is not an overreaction to that indignity.
Yuck.
And then you add to the yuck by turning to the desert floor
digging and digging and getting your tongue down there and covered with sand and Calling it.
Oh, that's good It's insane.
It's a great evil.
It's a great evil Most of the world doesn't have a clue what evil is they think evil is treating other people badly That's a spin-off
The great evil is looking God in the face and saying, you are very unattractive.
And I'm not interested.
I've got other things that satisfy me.
Thank you very much.
And how can people I love with all my heart that are doing that?
Don't be one of them and pleading with you on behalf of your parents or your kids.
Don't be insane.
Don't be evil.
That's number four.
The opposite of pursuing your joy in Jesus is to fall into the evil of all evils.
Number five, there are six of these who are almost done.
You can't love other people the way the Bible says to love other people if you're not
Pursuing your enjoyment in Jesus.
You can't.
And the key text for me, this has been a very, very impactful text for me, is 2 Corinthians eight, one and two, which goes like this.
Paul is talking to the Corinthians who live in a caya, the lower part of Greece, about the Corinthians,
The Macedonians who live in the northern part, and he's using the Macedonians as an illustration for how the Corinthians ought to act.
Okay, that's what's going on.
We want you to know, brothers, about the grace of God that has been given in the churches of Macedonia.
That's Thessalonica, Philippi.
The grace of God that has been given in the churches of Macedonia, because in a severe test of affliction,
their abundance of joy and their extreme poverty have overflowed in a wealth of generosity on their part.
And then later on in verse 8 he calls that overflow of generosity, love.
So my question is where does love come from in this text?
How did love come about?
How did it happen that these Macedonians were suddenly eager to help the poor in Jerusalem?
They didn't even know these people.
And they're asking for a second offering to be taken.
That's what it actually says in the next verse.
They're begging for the privilege to participate in another offering for the poor.
What is going on?
And you know that it is not some, it's not owing to the fact that they were
suddenly prosperous.
They weren't prosperous.
It says that they were in extreme poverty, verse two.
Extreme poverty.
What about security and comfort?
Had they come into some new security and comfort?
No, they hadn't.
They were in much affliction, a severe test of affliction.
So you've got a brand new set of believers who are still in poverty and they're
still in affliction or probably greater affliction.
And it says their abundance of joy is overflowing in generosity.
I just want to be that.
I want to be that.
And I want to go places and speak so that when I'm done, that happens.
Because I think the world looks on us.
And if they don't see something like that happening, they would say, how are these things different than me?
So why were they happy?
They weren't happy because they had just gotten rich, they weren't happy because they had just escaped affliction, more affliction, steal poverty, and they're so super happy that the happiness is overflowing in love.
Why?
What were they happy about?
And the only clue we have is verse 1, I want you to know, brothers, about the grace of God.
that has been given among the churches of Macedonia.
Paul had walked into Philippi and walked into Thessalonica, he had preached the gospel, and the Holy Spirit had opened the hearts like Lydia, he'd opened the hearts of the people, and they had seen, you mean, for nothing that we do, our sins can be forgiven, and the wrath of God can be turned away, and the creative, the universe can become our
friend and we can be adopted into his family and we can live forever in full and forever joy with him.
Are you kidding me?
And that was just staggeringly good news.
All that we could stay in love with the good news.
It just staggered them that this was true.
What else could possibly matter if that were true?
I'm living forever as a child of God.
What else matters?
And they just gave everything.
Come on, let me show how not in bondage to stuff.
So I argue you can't love people as you ought unless that happens.
Not according to this text, joy in God and his grace is what becomes abundant, like a fountain, then overflows.
So my definition of love on the basis of these two verses is
Love is the overflow of joy in God that meets the needs of others.
And if you don't pursue your joy in God, you're not going to be able to pursue love.
Argument number six and lastly, and this is the most important.
It is our duty to pursue full and lasting pleasure in Jesus because without it, you cannot glorify God.
You cannot glorify God.
What is man's chief end?
Westminster Catechism.
The chief end of man is to glorify God and enjoy him forever.
And what we have done at Desiring God, what I've done for 50 plus years is to say actually the word and there is most fully understood by using the word by.
What is the chief end of man?
The chief end of man is to glorify God by.
enjoying him forever.
And then you start looking in the Bible, you start looking in church history and you find it everywhere.
I'll give you one text.
So here's Paul.
This was the text with which I came to my church in 1980.
So, so desirous that this would come true.
He said, it is my eager expectation and hope.
That was mine.
I hope it's yours tonight.
It is my eager expectation and hope that I will not at all be ashamed, but that with full courage, now as always, Christ would be magnified, or you could say glorified, in my body, whether by life or by death, for to me to live as Christ and to die as gain.
And I remember looking at that argument and thinking, how does that work?
Christ is magnified in my body as I die because for me to die is gain.
That doesn't work yet.
There's a premise missing in the argument.
I met a lady last night.
I hope she's here because I want to thank her out loud who said, I like your preaching because it's mathematical.
Bless you, wherever you are.
So I got on the phone with my wife and said, I met this wonderful lady who likes my preaching because it's like math.
And my wife said, of course it's like math.
It's like premises and conclusions.
So here we got a lot of argument and there's a missing premise.
All of you excited about that?
What's the missing premise?
Christ will be made to look magnificent by the way I die because when I die, I experience death as gain.
Something's missing.
What's missing is verse 23 where it supplies to depart from the body is to be with the Lord.
The gain is Christ.
That's verse 23.
That's the missing piece.
So now you can finish the argument and see how it relates to the glory of Christ or the glory of God.
I want Christ to be magnified in my life, in my body, whether by life or by death.
So it's gonna be, he's gonna look great in my death if I experience death as gain and he's the gain.
Now can you put all that together?
A good mathematician could.
I mean, an ordinary human could, because you have brains.
In spite of the fact that they're not the essential thing of your humanity.
The key is Christ is most magnified in us when we are most satisfied in Him, especially when we're dying.
Right?
Your kids gather around the hospital bed, and Daddy's dying.
I fully expect this is going to happen.
I mean, I might go out real suddenly so it can't happen, but this is probably the way it's going to happen.
You're in the hospital bed.
I've got five kids.
I've got spouses, 16 grandkids.
They're all gathering around.
What's it going to be like?
If I turn on Jesus at that moment, if Jesus is not
present, real and precious and satisfying at that moment.
It's going to make him look real bad.
And two of those boys need to see it look good.
Get it?
If you're going to glorify Jesus, he got to desire Jesus above all things.
God is made to look most glorious when we desire him above all things.
Okay, those are my six
arguments for why you cannot treat the enjoyment of Jesus as something peripheral, marginal, non-essential, it is very essential.
God, you made known to me the path of life in your presence is fullness of joy at your right hand or pleasures forever more.
And I would just look out upon you even though it's dark and I can't see faces real clearly.
You can see mine, it's real big over there probably.
And I just wanna close by saying, if that's not the way you experienced Jesus, or the way you experienced God, as the fullness of joy, the forever joy, that verse from Psalm 16 is an invitation to you.
I call it an obligation, but it's such a happy obligation.
And God is saying to you tonight, my arms are wide to you, I love being enjoyed.
That's the way I get glory is if people enjoy me.
So I'm inviting you.
Come.
Enjoy me.
It's free.
My son covered all your sins.
My son provided a way into my favor.
I'll adopt you into my family.
You will live with me forever.
You will be as happy as you can possibly be.
You will never be bored forever and ever.
That's why I have
giving you my book.
That's why I sent John Piper down to middle of the end.